[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN HANSMAN: MIT has an
educational philosophy
of learning by doing.
So it's fine to know about
the theoretical equations.
It's quite another
thing when you actually
have to build something.
And for a lot of students,
this is the first time
they've ever built anything.
If you take RTV, it's
kind of a rubber, so--
Capstone class, it's where
you take the different things
you've learned in your
undergraduate education
and pull them into something
that integrates them.
In our case, we
do capstone class
looking at the design
and construction
of either an airplane
or a spacecraft.
CASEY DENHAM: There's
a lot of systems
that I've gotten-- a lot
of recognition that started
with a senior capstone class.
So it would always be awesome to
be the next iteration of that.
PROFESSOR: 3, 2, 1,
and we're flying.
BOB SHIN: These
innovative solutions
the students come up with, it
is a challenging problem, that's
really unique.
And that's what I
suppose is really value.
STUDENT: How do we,
like, connect to i?
TONY TAO: You don't really build
much in the first semester,
and you're not meant to.
The idea is for everyone to come
in to work with their models,
to come up with
ideas and sketches.
And in the spring, you
take the old designs
and you iterate on
them experimentally.
And then you build them, and
you try to get the thing to fly.
SHANELA CLARKE: We
wanted to create
an unmanned aerial vehicle along
with a submersible system that
will be used to either conduct
reconnaissance or search
and rescue missions in
blue-water operations.
JOHN HANSMAN: The project
was sponsored by the Office
of Naval Research.
And the motivation was
to be able to resupply
a UAV in deep water when
you're away from land.
SHANELA CLARKE: When
I first heard of it,
I was like, oh, wow,
this is so cool.
STUDENT: One of the major
problems with seaplanes
is that they can dig
their pontoons in and flip
upon landing.
JOHN HANSMAN: The
students came up
with a relatively ingenious idea
of having the pontoons rotate
so that if the airplane
did end up on its back,
it wouldn't be like
a turtle on its back.
It would be able to
get flipped over.
STUDENT: There is a worm gear
system inside the airplane that
tilts the pontoons so it kind
of does an upside down push-up.
Then the body actually is
lifted out of the water,
and then the body is then
free to rotate around.
JOHN HANSMAN: There's
a very strong software
in autonomy component.
So the pod knows where it is
with its local GPS system.
So it broadcasts a
message to the airplane,
I'm at this location.
The airplane comes and lands
close to that location.
They use an optical
camera that was
sensitive to certain colors.
They put colored
markers on the pod
so that the optical
system would know to look
for the signature of the pod.
That sounds pretty
easy, but it actually
gets tough because now
you're in rough water.
So the pod isn't still.
It's going up and down.
The airplane's being
bounced around.
So it has to find
the target, and it
has to sort of average out
where the target's going to be
and head in that direction.
As it gets closer and closer,
it gets a better and better fix.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: Is someone
recording the settings?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Okay, good,
I didn't know that.
Ready?
All right.
Full power.
TONY TAO: Pontoons are
submarining at speed,
and I don't have
enough Q on the tail
to be able to bring the nose up.
STUDENT: Yeah.
TONY TAO: And we couldn't
get the airplane to take off.
We tried a couple different
angles and flap settings
and couldn't get it to take off.
Diagnosed it as the
pontoons submarining down
into the water.
Did a quick fix with that, just
mixed up some glue and pieces
of plywood to try to get
the pontoons to sit up
a little better.
STUDENT: Takeoff attempt 2.2.
STUDENT: Whoo, whoo!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TONY TAO: You take it to
the field and you try it.
And if it doesn't
work, you take video
and you take
measurements, and you
use that to refine your design.
JOHN HANSMAN: First
flight test, first crash.
It's sort of the way it
goes in this business.
STUDENT: OK.
Let me try it.
It's got a little too
much here to start with.
DENNIS PRIETO: It didn't
actually get to fly,
but we did learn what we need
to be able to fly basically.
We hadn't done enough
surface area attachment
on the inside of
the carbon fiber.
So the legs actually
sheared, and we
weren't able to
take off properly
on the final take-off attempt.
And then before
that, we realized
that our tail needed to be
a little bit bigger so we
could have more nose
control, nose authority.
And then those are some
of the modifications
that we made so far,
and hopefully it'll
fly on Wednesday.
Awesome.
JOHN HANSMAN:
They're figuring out
how things that look good on
paper, theoretical models,
work in the real world.
They're understanding that you
have to make approximations.
You have to use
engineering judgment.
You have to decide
what's important
and what's not important.
STUDENT: Oh, no.
They glued it in wrong.
TONY TAO: After the
flight test at the pond,
we made a bunch of
changes to the aircraft.
First of all, the
biggest change is
that we took the tail, which was
here and which was too small,
gave it a bigger
tail and put it here
in the prop wash of the motors.
And we included these scoops
at the front of the pontoons
to help with the pitch
stability and the submarining
problem on the water.
And all these design changes
have been carried over
onto the new aircraft,
which has these hooks here
to allow the water to
separate and for it
to build up high pressure.
That keeps the pontoons from
nose-diving into the water.
And this one has also been
given a molded Kevlar fuselage
to improve the aerodynamics
and keep everything inside.
SHANELA CLARKE: What's special
about the capstone process
is the fact that it's really
simulating the engineering
environment.
BOB SHIN: Many of the students
describe their experience
as transformational.
They become fearless.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAN: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
MAN: Automatic.
Everybody, it's in
automatic mode now.
TONY TAO: The fact that
they get to experience
being both an engineer
and a technician, somebody
who actually is the one who puts
these things together, I think,
makes them better
engineers because they
can learn to understand how
their designs could actually
be built.
[MUSIC PLAYING]